you got a couple of ideas about how we
might fix some of this national
conversation social media uh you talk
about having returning to a rational
public it's hard to fix congress and
it's hard to fix the economy if you
can't fix the conversation what are some
things we could do that could fix a
conversation number one is local
journalism it turns out that local
papers tended to be
much less polarizing because
you know you're actually kind of the
glue of the community and you're talking
about things that aren't particularly
partisan in nature so getting rid of
local news sources means that more
people turn to cable news and
polarization gets worse
and then the biggest problem is social
media and the question is how the heck
do you bring back social media and what
i suggest is something big
uh because i'm a big idea guy um but
it's that we should try and get rid of
the advertising business model on social
media and the way i suggest doing that
is just have the government give
everyone money i'm a big fan of giving
everyone money that essentially just
trues up all of our social media
uh
advertising
um to a point where you can just opt
into
ad free facebook youtube
twitter you name it and then the social
media company gets a little bit of money
from the us government and then all of
us all of a sudden
uh have better information environment
um and if you think about as a
difference between something like
netflix and youtube uh where netflix
there's a subscription fee and there's
content um but it doesn't have the same
uh desire to plunge you down a rabbit
hole as youtube does because youtube
it's like oh like you know we gotta try
and get you to watch something else and
so
that to me is the kind of dramatic shift
you would need
because right now social media is
leading us
to ruin and mental illness and
depression
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone today on the forward
podcast a little bit different kind of
show
we're sharing with you an episode i
recorded with my friend van jones for
his podcast uncommon ground we had what
felt like a really important
conversation so we wanted to share it
here as well those of you who supported
me on the presidential remember van was
one of the earliest most prominent
voices saying gang gang
on the national stage he and i have
remained friends we're looking to make
common cause so was excited to be one of
the first guests on his new podcast
uncommon ground with van jones hope you
enjoy the conversation let's find common
ground with people am i right
[Music]
welcome back to uncommon ground i'm van
jones on this show we explore what it
takes to make meaningful change in such
a divided country and my next guest is
somebody who has thought a lot about
that very question it's andrew yang and
before i start bragging on him and
telling everything
that he's done
i just want to tell you why i love this
guy so much a lot of times i feel
trapped
between the people who just want to
defend the status quo
the kind of establishment types that
just want everybody to kind of go away
calm down be civil pay your taxes and
basically shut up versus the people who
just want to burn everything down
whether on the left or on the right and
i don't agree
with either group i do think that
there's
something really wrong with our system
with our society people are being let
down the earth is dying we aren't
solving real problems at the same time
the idea that you know you just you know
pick somebody to blame a racial group or
an income group and just burn it all
down that makes no sense to me either
what we need is a third way out not
people defending the status quo as if
nothing's wrong not the people who want
to burn it all down but people have got
positive ideas and andrew yang is just
full of positive ideas positive
solutions i think he's the best guy in
american politics right now and you know
uh
he's obviously become something of a
household name he's an entrepreneur he's
a philanthropist he's an author
his new book called forward notes on the
future of democracy came out recently i
highly recommend it but he's best known
for his rise in politics he ran for
president in 2020 one of the most
successful
asian american candidates in american
history i guess kamala harris would have
to be number one and he ran on a big big
idea universal basic income that
everybody in the country especially with
the rise of the robots should be
guaranteed a basic floor of income that
they can use to meet their needs or to
start their business and that idea was
nowhere until andrew yang put it on the
map and now it's very much a mainstream
idea
he ran for mayor of new york recently
that didn't work out and now he is
leading a new political party called the
forward party which is trying to reform
the u.s political and economic systems
to try to reduce polarization and so if
you are looking for ideas and hope and
solutions you need to look no further
than andrew yang when we get back
[Music]
you know what i love to do that you also
love to do
sleep we spend about a third of our
lives on our mattress and it's important
to have the right mattress what did you
do you probably did what most people did
where you went into a store you got
talked into something but today we can
do better you can take a two minute quiz
for the perfect mattress at helix sleep
and then get the best mattress you've
ever had sent to your door
i did this i gotta say it's a game
changer imagine sleeping better and what
that does for you your health your
energy the overall mattress pick of 2020
for gq and wired magazine helix sleep go
to
helixsleep.com take their two minute
sleep quiz get a customized personalized
mattress and the best sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com yang
their pillows are dope too
helixsleep.com
[Music]
well it is an honor to have you on
uncommon ground podcast uh a lot of what
i'm trying to do
really been inspired by you oh my gosh
man that that's seriously
[Music]
but uh no man just the idea i mean you
kind of came out of nowhere this kind of
like comet of hope this kind of
supernova of solutions and really i
think had such a positive impact on the
2020 election and now you've written a
book i want to get into the book but
really i mean you've seen it all now you
were an entrepreneur
watching the
world go south for working-class people
you've been a not-for-profit leader now
you've run for office national level
local level
you know you should be depressed i get
considered how tough these problems are
you've seen them all up close how are
you holding up
thanks for asking van uh
the presidential race was a journey that
i did try and catalog in the book and
then when that campaign ended it was
like a bit of
being one of those cartoon characters
who's been like running running and then
you're like off the cliff and you're
looking around you're like
what's going on
uh and so that was a massive adjustment
and then i
ran for mayor and that was an
extraordinarily difficult race
and so coming off of that race
i definitely needed a little bit of time
with the family and
some sunshine in the summer
but the ideas i laid out in this book
uh are so needed right now and so
i feel really invigorated by the
possibility of getting these ideas out
because my journey through the
presidential race in particular
led me to
understand more fully why it feels like
we can't get anything done um and
unfortunately we're being set up we are
being set up to not get much done and
there are all of these
people i feel like who are losing hope
right now
at the end of the day when what we're
going through right now it's a crisis of
the imagination i think it's a crisis a
human heart human soul like things are
changing so fast and i think change is
scary for a lot of people left and right
or otherwise and when you get scared you
get small when you get small you get
mean you get mean you start having a
self-fulfilling kind of experience where
other people start being mean to you and
you can wind up in a civil war in the
country if you're not careful i think
the biggest fear that people have is
that they're not gonna be able to feed
their families and so
people who've got
good economic ideas i think are really
key and you've got some in the book can
you just talk a little bit about how you
see the economy what's going wrong and
how we can fix some of it any of it the
central problem is that we've started to
treat the capital e economy as if it's
its own goal
with its own heads
meanwhile our quality of life has eroded
to 28th in the world by
measurements like
clean air and clean water public
education infant mortality life
expectancy like the basics
meanwhile the stock market is
gangbusters and everything else
and so i'm
a straightforward thinker where i'm
saying well you know if you are trying
to to
uh
increase stock market prices then i
guess that's what you're gonna get like
we should be trying to increase people's
uh life expectancy and education rates
and the quality of the environment and
if you made that the
measuring stick and the goal of progress
then all of a sudden every quarter you'd
have all like well we're still terrible
at this and then you know your public
officials would have a different set of
goals they'd be like oh well you know
28th that's pretty terrible and let's
try and get up to 25th i think that
that's true and at the same time
uh you know you got some pretty uh
bright answers and the universal basic
income idea which is now well known but
wasn't before you is that everybody
should get a thousand dollars period um
and it's just your money you do it what
you want to that was a crazy idea but
you have this other idea that's kind of
you know really new and different which
is tax the robot
why would taxing the robots make a
difference how's that even gonna scratch
the surface most people never thought
about that
more and more of the work that people
do
is going to be done by technology in the
days to come and our tax system right
now is going to do a terrible job of
capturing any of that value
where if you use google's ai to answer
phones there are two million americans
right now that are in call centers so
they pay taxes uh most most of them and
so
then you ask okay how much is google
gonna pay in taxes if it's software is
doing this and the answer is next to
nothing you look at the tax rate of
these tech companies they just move it
through ireland or wherever the heck and
we don't see a dime so we're stuck in a
situation where
the value is going to be slipping
through our fingers more and more unless
we actually capture a toll on that and
if we do capture a toll on that by the
way it could amount to hundreds of
billions of dollars trillions of dollars
very very quickly because the value so
immense
and to me it points to a freshness of
approach that i think you represent i
think that both parties really need like
what you just said i don't think anybody
can argue with from the left or the
right if they thought about it there's
not an automatic constituency for or
against that has already been trained by
their political media to hate it or like
it and you know which really kind of
brings me to the other point about your
book you know you're talking about
rewiring the government
i'm very worried about democracy me too
i don't like
what i'm seeing it seems to me that
we now have
even at the level of voting
you have both sides
maybe less and less willing to accept
the results of elections i think you've
popped a hood on that and you've got
some ideas as well that i think we're
talking about talk a little bit about
this idea of open primaries and ranked
choice voting especially given that you
kind of had experience with that in new
york and you didn't win that election so
does it change your perspective on it i
mean how do you having actually thought
about it and argued for it and then
participated in it talk a little bit
about this idea of you know ranked
choice voting which they had in new york
well this to me is the recipe then right
now
the approval rate for congress is 28
pretty low people aren't happy
the re-election rate for individual
members of congress is 92 percent i
almost guarantee job security and the
there are two main reasons why
these numbers don't match very well
number one is that 83
of the district races are safe seats
it's going to be either a democrat or
republican so if you get to the general
you win
and people can all think about their own
district it's probably a safe seat
so then the criteria to get reelected is
not somehow doing a great job for
your district it's can you get through a
party primary where only the most
partisan 11 to 20 will vote
uh and so that's why you have political
figures who don't want to compromise and
are willing to make very extreme
statements because
they're just worried about the most
extreme 20
in their district
but one community's actually made this
change where now it's open primaries and
right towards voting and that state
you're not going to believe it everyone
is alaska which last year
flipped a switch and said no more party
primaries
and then this year
senator lisa murkowski
was the only republican senator to vote
to impeach donald trump who's also up
for reelection
in 22.
her approval rating among republicans in
alaska right now is six percent
according to one poll so
if she was subject to a party primary
she's obviously out of there this is
which is one reason why you're not
seeing many republicans say a bad word
about trump but now with open primaries
uh and ranked choice voting she actually
can make her case straight to all
alaskans and try and appeal to the 51
instead of the 10 to 20 at the extreme
so this is the big fix this is the
anti-polarization
recipe for the country
and believe it or not we don't even need
congress to do it that the way they did
in alaska was through a ballot
initiative that citizens led
we can just do the same in 24 other
states that allow for ballot initiatives
and then unlock our legislators from
this extreme polarization that is
unfortunately driving them to the
extreme to keep their jobs
[Music]
okay i'm gonna fess up
even andrew yang sometimes gets a little
bit down we're all a little bit down
because frankly you know it's kind it's
kind of a rough time out there if you
get down you need someone to talk to and
i have to say your friends and family
are good for about one conversation
then after that they're like take it
someplace else so you know where you
should take it
betterhelp.com
it's professional therapists on call
exactly when you need them i am so proud
to have them as a sponsor of the forward
podcast because they genuinely help
people feel better and live better lives
it's like uber for mental health
hopefully that's a positive
[Laughter]
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
yang i want you to do this if you could
use it and frankly just about all of us
could join over one million people who
have taken charge of our mental health
again that's better help
help dot com yang
[Music]
well i love that idea i think i don't
think we explain to people well enough
in the media how these incentives work
right now
it really doesn't matter you know if
literally you know you meet 10 people
and two of them can fire you and the
other eight aren't going to participate
or can't there's another party when i
say two percent can fire you what do i
mean i mean
it's a very small number of people
in that supermarket who are going to
vote in your primary if you're a
democrat you cannot vote in a republican
primary if you're republican you cannot
own democratic primaries you
automatically cut half the people out
just for the primary election and then
most people don't vote in primary
elections so you have another chop so it
you wind up we say why these people say
this crazy stuff why they seem so
extreme because they're talking to
weirdos they're talking to weirdos yes
and but if you're weirdo if a weirdo is
your boss if your weirdo can fire you
then you kind of have to talk a little
weird
it's not that we don't have good people
in elective office we do it set the
incentives
to act terribly are so overwhelming that
we require super human almost suicidal
levels of courage to do the right thing
even part of the time and so i love your
fixes because they do tend to go to the
core of the matter
you know i am very concerned about
where we're headed in the following
respect
there really should be a grand bargain
now on voting just voting itself the
republicans keep saying we we want to
cheat i'm a democrat they say we want to
cheat and we say we don't want to cheat
and then we say
you guys want to gerrymander and
suppress our vote on racial grounds
primarily and they say no we don't and
it turns out you can do this for a very
long time and nothing improves except
more and more division cynicism
hostility anger and possibly in 2022 and
2024 election results that millions of
people won't accept i mean it's all this
kind of thing so i feel i mean i'm
encouraged by your courage and putting
ideas out but do am i crazy if you are
concerned van you are right to be deeply
concerned i'm also deeply concerned
so one of the ways i think about it now
is that democrats have become the party
of institutionalists
and republicans have become the
anti-institutional party
and one measuring stick i throw in the
book that i think speaks to this is that
69 of democrats have a high trust in the
media
and if you look at republicans you're
down to 15
so so then if you go to to republicans
say hey lost that election i'd be like i
don't believe your vote and so now we
have these divergent versions of reality
and it's very very difficult to hammer
something out
we should be very very concerned and one
of the the deficiencies i'm seeing
is that if you were to build a democracy
and you would want it to be resilient to
authoritarianism let's say you would
definitely have a system that looks
nothing like ours like ours is actually
very very vulnerable to authoritarianism
because you have two major parties and
if one of them succumbs to an
authoritarian leader all of a sudden
everyone's political incentives are to
be in line with that leader
and you don't have much in the way of
additional safeguards if you were to
want to build a more resilient system
what you do is you'd be like the uk the
uk has five parties sweden has eight
parties netherlands has 18 parties and
then if one of those parties that comes
to bad leadership but then everyone's
like oh that party over there seems like
a little
off the rails but then that's not
existential but but the problem is that
you have this anti-institutional impulse
that's now
essentially
in command of one of the two major
parties and then the other major party
the democrats uh
have been put in this role where they're
defending these institutions that oh by
the way
some people have some serious problems
with and and like aren't really
delivering in
the ways that some some people hope or
some people would expect it to and so
the democrats are being placed in a very
tough spot in terms of the argument they
have to make it's like no no it is
working it is working and more and more
people are like is it working
maybe it's not you know when i was a
fellow at the center for american
progress back in ancient history now
tony blair came by to talk to us
and he predicted this
uh he said you know the right wing
comes on so strong that you find
yourself just trying to defend the whole
society against them and defend all the
institutions against them and you wind
up sounding like an apologist for the
status quo because you know you know
they're saying stuff they're saying is
so extreme they're coming on so hard
they position you as a defender of the
status quo and you then become a weapon
in their arsenal
because you know you're now a part of
the problem i mean one of the things i
like about you and i like about your
your book and in both your campaigns is
that you really would position yourself
as the reformer
that you were coming on
you know to me like you're our most
promising positive populist you're a
populist in that you're concerned about
ordinary people you're concerned about
the plight of working folks and regular
people but rather than being a negative
populist where you come on and say i'm
going to blame the immigrants or i'm
going to blame the billionaires i'm
going to blame this group i'm going to
blame that group you come on as a
positive populist with ideas that can
help everybody especially working people
and i think you know that is really
needs to be encouraged more because
otherwise you wind up either having to
blame a whole bunch of people who you
know may or may not be
at fault just because you want you don't
want to seem like you're a part of the
system or you you know you wind up
depending stuff that sucks
[Music]
oh i actually took your words to heart
on this van because you you talked to me
about how i'm like the this positive
populist figure it meant a lot to me
and i hope to be
this animating force around a degree of
optimism and solutions orientation and
universality
that is very very absent from our
politics right now our politics is very
disheartening and depressing so
i hope to be
the someone who can positively channel
some of this energy
and then keep us from this
this
binary
clash that is going to doom us really
and you know part of the reason i think
we feel bad is because social media
takes all this stuff and makes it feel
even worse you got a couple of ideas
about how we might fix some of this
national conversation social media you
talk about having returning to a
rational public it's hard to fix
congress it's hard to fix the economy if
you can't fix the conversation how what
are some things we could do that could
fix a conversation number one is local
journalism but it turns out that local
papers tended to be
much less polarizing because
you know you you're
actually kind of the glue of the
community and you're talking about
things that aren't particularly partisan
in nature so getting rid of local news
sources means that more people turn to
cable news and polarization gets worse
and then the biggest problem is social
media and the question is how the heck
do you bring back social media and what
i suggest is something big
uh because i'm a big idea guy um but
it's that we should try and get rid of
the advertising business model on social
media
and the way i suggest doing that is just
have the government give everyone money
i'm a big fan of giving everyone money
that essentially just trues up all of
our social media
uh
advertising
um to a point where you can just opt
into
ad free facebook youtube
uh twitter you name it and then the
social media company gets a little bit
of money from the us government and then
all of us all of a sudden uh have better
information environment um and if you
think about it as a difference between
something like
netflix and youtube uh where netflix
there's a subscription fee and there's
content um but it doesn't have the same
uh desire to plunge you down a rabbit
hole as youtube does because youtube
it's like oh like you know we got to try
and get you to watch something else and
so
that to me is the kind of dramatic shift
you would need um because right now
social media is leading us
uh to ruin and mental illness and
depression yeah look i i i'm very
interested in trying to figure this out
as a part of the
the media i do feel like we're somehow
um accelerating the bad stuff and
decelerating the good stuff and and the
worst part about it is it doesn't seem
to be anybody's intention to do that i i
know a lot of people in hollywood and
silicon valley whatever nobody seems to
have the intention
of creating this downward spiral but
here we are
yeah this is something too that i want
people to understand is that right now
there are a lot of folks in american
life who are like oh there's someone in
there playing the strings and like you
know making things yeah yeah we wish
we go find them and give them a good
talking to
yeah
mo most
most of this and this is actually in
some ways more dangerous and darker
but most of it is that you have
reasonable people in systems of very
very messed up incentives and then it's
leading us to ruin
um and so that that to me again has to
be the core mission is to get our heads
back and up and say wait a minute i do
have these feelings and affiliations but
right now my tribalism is getting ginned
up to a level that might not be helping
me or the country uh and uh how am i
actually going to try and
uh line up the incentives with the
common good um so i have big ideas in
terms of government um but we're at a
dangerous time because if reasonable
people do rational things where we're
sunk
but look i'm glad i'm glad you say that
because i do think that you know the
conspiracy
chic now on both the left and the right
is getting in the way because it's much
worse than that if there were you know
12 people in a room someplace twirling
their mustaches we could go find them
and just you know put better people in
there something like that everybody
who's trapped in these systems believes
well you know we're one vote away or one
small tweak away or you know one bill
away or one
product launch away from having a better
outcome it's just not true that the
paradigm that we have been operating
inside of has divorced itself from the
the functional reality of modern day
economy modern day environment modern
day demographics
and people are just in there doing what
makes sense to them without really
anybody flying the plane anymore so i
think it requires depolarization i think
it requires us to come together i think
it requires us to think deeply to care a
lot
and to put forward both ideas which is
what you're doing and i think it's
really really key
[Music]
let me just say you know you're the
first
asian-american
national politician i remember
in 84 and 88
uh when reverend jackson ran for
president reverend jesse jackson it
changed my life it's sort of a lost
chapter now in american history people
don't remember or refer back it was
doing like you know reagan bush era
conservatism was really on the rise we
had very few voices
and the only time i saw my father cry
was
watching him
watch reverend jackson address a
democratic convention in 84.
just the idea that an african-american
man could stand in front of the nation
and have his own ideas and have his own
solutions and of his own critique
and make it to that level
and
it was 20 years 88 was 20 years after dr
king was killed and 20 years before
obama was elected so it was really kind
of this 40 years in the wilderness for
us as black folks
68
king is killed 2008 obama was elected in
that 40-year wilderness reverend jackson
really was like a central post for us so
i know the importance of
someone who looked like me
standing before the country you have
arisen as this incredible figure at a
moment where there's hate crimes against
asian americans uh where the president
united states was
saying things that were inflammatory
with regard to the virus
and it's kind of like it seems like the
best and the worst of all possible
worlds for you
as a figure i just wanted you to speak
about that as uh
as somebody who has become a historic
figure in a very difficult time thanks
van uh i confess to some people who are
close to me
that one of my goals in running for
president was to get on that debate
stage because i thought it would be
immensely meaningful for asian americans
to see
one of us on that debate stage and when
i came off that debate stage in miami
that first time and i saw the image even
i was like who's the asian guy
that was really i was like
i had to do a double take
um so that meant an immense amount to me
and to a lot of people
um who i met on the trail where when i
was in iowa or new hampshire wherever
there'd be asian families that bring
their kids up and have a picture with me
and say look you know oh you can do
anything
and um i'm so proud of that i certainly
feel
a responsibility as one of the more
visible asian americans in the country
to try and do things that can help bring
us together
and i say to asian-american communities
uh that
that can be something that we actually
try and lead on is trying to bring this
country back together and you'd think
asian americans would be kind of like an
unlikely group to lean on that honestly
but
but what i say to them is like look
no i mean we're
um
yeah
we're kind of this um
my
group in the middle is what i described
like the the asian americans and ronnie
chang the comedian talked about how it's
like you know we're we're here to
navigate uh america through its black
weight conflicts
american groups it's that look but this
country really needs us and can use us
and we have to do everything we can yeah
well look i am
uh you're somebody you're definitely
doing all you can and uh it's all you
can ask
my grandmother used to say do your best
angels can do no more
and you know people who i think see
folks like you or me on tv the public
eye they may have some idea that it's
not all cake and ice cream it's really
not it's really tough and therefore you
have every excuse to be mean to be
grumpy uh to dismiss people to be crappy
and i've seen you talk to just the i
mean just walking down the street with
you and just any person you treat them
with so much respect so much dignity and
so much curiosity i mean i think one of
the reasons why you know why you're so
good at what you do is not just because
you're a great presenter you're also
just a great listener and a great person
and i'm just so honored to have you on
this podcast i'm honored to be a part of
your life you know uh i think i think we
can save democracy but it'll take the
kind of leadership that you've been
showing and uh and i appreciate you
brother love you van jones and i i
genuinely dislike people i think that's
one reason why you and i get along that
you know we have an actual interest in
human beings
yeah
uh true it's true i encourage everybody
to get the book it's called forward
notes on the future of our democracy
it's by andrew yang you got a little
tiny taste on this podcast where you get
the whole gulp that he's offering up
appreciate you brother thanks man great
being here
[Music]
you